ladies and gentlemen we have our guest
is here and it's the one and only james
Van Der Beek ever to give a round of
applause everybody
James yes thank you so much for being
here thank you for my mineral or water
and um I wanted you on this for sure but
I didn't want to intrude you know
because we work together yes on what
would Diplo do yeah and I want to start
off by is Dumba when we first met I do I
remember what happened well alright some
you want my breakfast yeah yeah okay so
um I'd written this character yeah and
Rick Messina our casting director sends
over lists of people yeah
at the very top is Bobby Lee and I was
like hey I've heard this before you know
I was up so I was onyl I was on the who
is number one
you were literally topple is number one
dr. Kent was not number one dr. ken was
greats okay go ahead keep going ah I
believe he was unavailable no I'm
kidding um and so you know I was
familiar with you I'd known you work I
don't know that I'd seen much scripted
stuff but I googled you
yeah yeah and then I saw you on talk
shows yeah and I watched you harassing
guests oh I'm touching touching like
local morning host sitting on laps
making like grown men very uncomfortable
and I was like yeah this is our [ __ ]
guy yeah this is this is based on what's
his name
well you're kind of an amalgam yeah but
what was it yeah what Diplo's manager is
asian but not [ __ ] not only brought all
the asian people are the same oh there's
that family that's true thank you he is
a wild Asian hey he's a character but we
I mean listen every everybody in the
show kind of started out inspired by
somebody
like H Michael corners character was he
plays the kronor yeah on the character
his character is inspired by a German
guy who I met at West's house
dibbles house and then this other dude
who always wears a suit was like his
kind of tour manager
so like I'm molded same thing with your
character really yeah
but but yeah so I watched you I need to
them like this's our guy this is in
branded Dermer who directed every
episode yeah on a partner in this
completely agreed a hundred percent
we're like yeah Papa that's gotta be
Bobby who else there's nobody popular
yeah it has to be about Italy everybody
and then so we made the offer told Rick
Messina offered to Bobby Lee yeah and
and you passed
yes do you know why I was told money it
was maybe it was good it was maybe the
shittiest money TV money you'd ever been
it was fine what it was is this okay
okay
number one I know who you are right and
I was like oh him I'm not I'm not
feeling the enthusiam see the James man
you're my agent
oh there's this new Diplo show with
james van der beek Wow Bobby and then
they said Brandon Dryden know who the
[ __ ] that was right I go how much and
then I go you know I just I just too
much on my plate which I had really not
that much but I was just like cuz of the
money I had to make an excuse right so I
passed and then what happened was I get
a call from Andrew Santino he's been
right hard cast right and Santino said
um you gotta at least meet him like a
who he goes James and Brandon I call all
right he goes there Brendan's really
talented and just meet him as soon as I
would met you got as soon as I walked in
the door yeah I was I was gonna say ass
that's awesome
[Music]